[Music]
welcome back we are once again here with
another episode of what's up prof and
walter hello hi martin how are you i'm
the same as last time yeah this time you
uh
picked quite a odd
title yes
it's an odd title
it's a singular title
and i don't trade extremists i hope you
don't have any intention of trying to
maybe
put it towards us
i i wouldn't i wouldn't do a thing like
that
no
let's open with a word of prayer
heavenly father thank you so much we are
here once again we need your
enlightenment we need your
guidance and everything that you can
provide for us because we can do nothing
on our own we ask that in jesus name
amen amen
martin
we have been warned that if you do your
duty you will be considered an odd
singular straight-laced extremist
and i think it's time that we address
some of these things i don't want to
become too personal
but there are some issues that need to
be addressed
and
it just is a fact
that there is a divide in the church
and there are two groups forming and
whether we like it or not it's a reality
and so
we need to be able to talk about it
now when it comes to the individuals
that are on the other side of let's say
our thinking
that doesn't mean that we condemn the
individuals
but it certainly does mean that we
condemn what they stand for and say
always
jesus never condemned the person no he
always condemned the sin yes
so let's look at it in that light and
we spoke last time about division
and
we cannot deny that there is a division
and this division runs deep
and to to sweep it under the rug is not
a solution and unfortunately there's
deception along with the division yes
so we have to look at it very carefully
because
we are definitely
in the firing line
and so are they in the firing line
because both sides are shooting
now
we are admonished to let the truth do
the cutting
so let's not become too personal
but let's
deal with the issue
second chronicles chapter 20 verse 20
tells us and they arose early in the
morning and went forth into the
wilderness of tikkawa
and as they went forth jehoshaphat stood
and said hear me o judah and ye
inhabitants of jerusalem
believe in the lord your god so shall ye
be established believe his prophet so
shall ye prosper
ye is plural
so he's addressing
all the people
and he's saying that if you want to be
established you have to believe
god
you have to believe his prophets
and then only can you
flourish
to the law
and to the testimony
now the remnant does it have the
testimony yes and is the testimony
according to revelation chapter 19 the
spirit of prophecy yes
okay two legs
you don't you cannot stand on one you
have to believe the lord your god and
you have to believe his prophets
now we're reading testimonies for the
church and we're going to be reading
quite a number of testimonies today
and some of them are well known and
people might say you know why are you
reading them again
because it seems to me that some people
don't want to be established now
and the problem is we've got a message
the remnant as a message
three angels messages to be exact and it
has to be preached to the world
but if you are not
established
how can you do this now if you if you
deny the veracity of the three angels
messages
can you call yourself a seventh-day
adventist no and that's i think this
message that we have today
is guided towards that because there's
qualifications to be part of the remnant
church yes
but why is it that some
who
arrive themselves against the message
are the very ones that are in leadership
position and are the ones teaching our
youth
at our colleges
you see unfortunately the bible tells us
this will be so
the difference is you have a choice
in are you going to be misled
by these people
or are you going to see through them so
let's have a look at some of the
statements and then we'll address the
issues
we read in testimonies for the church
the world is stirred with the spirit of
war
the prophecy of the 11th chapter of
daniel has nearly reached its complete
fulfillment
soon the scenes of trouble spoken of in
the prophecies will take place
is this future yes
is this pertaining to her time or to
future future future
now we've dealt with that in the
previous what's up so we're not going to
go into any of those details
i was shown
the inhabitants of the earth in the
utmost confusion war
bloodshed privation
want
famine
pestilence we're abroad in the land
are these things abroad in the land yes
my attention was then called from the
scene there seems to be a little time of
peace
once more the inhabitants of the earth
were presented before me and again
everything was in the utmost confusion
strife war bloodshed famine pestilence
raged
everywhere
and we discussed this last time that's
it
we've had turmoils we've had a second
world war we had the first world war
we've had war all along
and then there was this short period of
relative peace into which we were born
and now again
there will be all of these issues strife
war bloodshed famine pestilence and
they're going to be everywhere
other nations were engaged in this war
and confusion
right
other nations and we are seeing this
happening
war caused famine
have we got warnings that certain wars
taking place now will cause famine oh
we've shown it over and over in a few
episodes already want and bloodshed
caused
pestilence and then men's heart failed
them for fear and for looking after
those things which are coming on the
earth this is a serious warning is this
for a time past or for a time
in her future
i think you're blind if you think this
was only in the past
okay so
these prophecies apply to the times that
we are living in right
in our day as of old the vital truths of
god's word are set aside for human
theories and speculations
is this happening
yes but unfortunately sometimes
these people with the speculations and
theories are the fact checkers
okay
many professed ministers of the gospel
do not accept the whole bible as the
inspired word
is that a fact definitely
one wise man rejects one portion another
questions another part they set up their
judgment as superior to the word
and the scripture which they do teach
rests on their own authority
its divine authenticity is destroyed
thus the seeds of infidelity are sown
broadcast for the people become confused
and know not what to believe there are
many beliefs that the mind has no right
to entertain
now even within our own ranks i have sat
with prominent people in leadership
position who do not believe the creation
account
who are actually evolutionists
in my opinion they shouldn't be in the
remnant worship he were made the heavens
the earth the sea and the springs of
water and as it stands in the bible so
it is you either accept it or you cannot
call yourself
someone who believes
the law and the testimony
wickedness is reaching a height never
before attained and yet many ministers
of the gospel are crying peace and
safety
wasn't our
previous one of our previous what's ups
about that about the heights attained
in terms of wickedness
but god's faithful messages are to go
steadily forward with their work clothed
with the panoply of heaven they are to
advance fearlessly and victoriously
never ceasing their warfare until every
soul within their reach shall have
received the message of truth for this
time
so there is a message which is for the
very time which we live in
what the prophet wrote about was not
about her time but about future
we also read and we've had this
statement many times in selected
messages
that the very last deception of satan
will be to make of non-effect the
testimony of the spirit of god
the testimonies will be made of
non-effect that doesn't mean they'll be
taken away no
they will just be said
this is not for our time it doesn't
apply to us
right
and who's the one who's going to work
him here
well where there's no vision the people
perish proverbs 29 18. and we've just
read the statement that believe in the
prophets
and believe god and you will be
established
satan will work ingeniously in different
ways and through different agencies to
unsettle the confidence of god's remnant
people in the true testimony
it's going to happen and unfortunately
it will also be with deception so
sometimes there might be people that are
quoting the prophet
and the spirit of prophecy
but they're doing it out of context or
they're doing it to
in a certain way to just bring about the
point that they want to bring about all
right so you either believe it or you
don't and this deception is of satan
so to make it of non-effect
is a deception from satan
and anybody who does that
is either knowingly or inadvertently
becoming an agent of satan
is that what the verse says is this what
that is what it says that's what it says
it's a rather sad statement
now
i have been reading some of the
documentation that has been coming out
within our own ranks
and
it is rather unnerving now i've had
these experiences for years so this is
nothing new we've shown also in previous
episodes yes
but let's address it and let's make sure
that we know where we stand
because
the gospel is not there to bring peace
but to bring division
clear
lines
and you either believe one thing or you
believe another thing but you cannot
call yourself
part of a remnant
that is supposed to preach the three
angels messages if you deny the very
basics
right it's impossible
now i know we've spoken a lot about
conspiracy theories
but what exactly is a conspiracy theory
that's important in the minds of some of
our liberal theologians
and leaders
what is a conspiracy
now when i've read articles that were
written in the past by prominent people
even union presidents that wrote
articles denying the very basics that
the papacy is the beast or that the mark
of the beast is what we have claimed
that it is throughout the ages right
now when they write things like that
then
they are highly indignant if they
receive an answer
and if there's anything contrary to
their thinking then you're branded a
straight list extremist right
but
we know that that will happen that's why
we chose this title now there were a
number of articles that appeared in the
press
and
this one is from bayern adventistan.a
this magazine
actually
brings articles to the fore by our
prominent
theologians and leaders and there were
actually two articles that were written
against conspiracy theories now we want
to know what conspiracy theories are now
the first article was a rather lengthy
article written by someone from the bri
and it warns against
accepting
conspiracy theories and how to avoid the
pitfalls of those that proclaim
conspiracy theories it wasn't so direct
but it was a rather lengthy argument
with in my opinion very little substance
but it did try and make the point
that
those that sort of fall into that
category according to their opinions
should be avoided and we should rather
stick to
mainstream thinking
but then there was another article
and it is in german so i will try and
translate as well as i can it's written
by a
theologian
from our most prominent german
college
and
that college in my opinion has taught
many things in the past which
do not rhyme with the three angels
messages in fact go directly against
them
so in my personal opinion i would be
very wary from anything that comes from
their pens but in any case what they are
writing here
gives us an idea of how they think
and this is important we need to
understand
how they think
and we must also realize that these
institutions
and people don't have a small voice
in the church yes often they represent
adventism
in
in in circles where
certain choices are made yeah like our
like we've mentioned before
when the general conference of the
seventh adventists have a session where
all the delegates from different
all over the world come together to have
a vote
these people also come and have a vote
and then other people
are removed and not allowed to be there
with a voice so then you seem to have a
biased voice right
and some of these people seem to
create the impression that they
represent the church
well they certainly don't represent me
no at all or many like-minded people as
myself or you so the title of this one
is vasmat adventist and felix fearful
schweinsteiger
what makes adventists susceptible to
conspiracy theories
now he's going to tell us what
conspiracy theories are and in
particular how they are defined in terms
of
the religious aspect of seventh-day
adventism that's important because here
for the first time they actually
spelling it out
and it's good for the people to see so
that they can make informed choices
so let's have a look at what he defines
as conspiracy theories which is the
normal things so
he's writing here and he's saying
that conspiracy theories
have had
a lot of hype in the world today and
they are
showing
that they have a message to bear that
they have
an outcome
so you have so-called
conspiracies for example that the jews
rule the world zionism
etc now we've never stood for any of
those we've basically
stuck to the bible and said that the
beast and the false prophet are the ones
that we should be watching out for
then he talks about the assassination
attempt of jfk
that that is a conspiracy theory the
whole question of the new world order
that's a conspiracy model even though
they're talking about it in congress
even though
congress people are exposing it and
speaking about it it's all a conspiracy
it's there's no facts associated with it
september 11 of course is one of their
favorites
and then the fact that there are
barcodes that's a conspiracy or donald
trump that stole the election
or the conspiracies surrounding the
covet 19 pandemic
so the only one
as i read between the lines here that is
acceptable or the only
story that is acceptable is that which
is propagated by mainstream media
and the thousands of doctors and
front-line doctors that do not agree
with the official position they are
conspirators yes and they're not allowed
a voice
anywhere they're not allowed a voice and
they're not allowed to speak and even if
there are
documents with thousands of signatures
even thousands of medical personnel they
are not allowed a voice and they're told
for example
that it's not a fundamental belief issue
but i thought our health message was a
fundamental belief issue
and i think it is up to the individual
that's my opinion at least to determine
what i will place in my body or not no
corporate body has the right to tell me
what to put into my body no and i also
for me personally i believe if they say
it's not a religious issue
is my
conscience
and the decision that i make with god
and that not a religious issue and isn't
it based on the fundamental belief isn't
our health message even if it is
secondarily
as
listed as a fundamental belief it is a
fundamental belief and therefore a issue
of conscience
so according to this writer
this is all conspiracy
so if you read about these then the one
or the other reader will have to nod his
head and say yes yes this is all
conspiracy theories
now this is what you generally assume
but he has another agenda he wants to
tell us exactly in a religious sense
what a conspiracy theory is we'll get to
that
so one of the criteria about a
conspiracy theory is that you cannot
prove them
and it's very difficult to
contradict them
because you can't prove them but you
can't contradict them either because
they present evidence these these
conspiracy theorists
so it is to them a issue of faith
so it's whether you believe this side or
the other side
so this really is important when it
comes to the religious
aspect of conspiracy theories
so once you link any of these things to
a religious aspect then you are on
dangerous ground according to this
particular writer
and now he's going to cut to the chase
and this is what i want to talk about
not to be antagonistic martin
no
not to be contrary
but to show a certain mindset with his
which is prevalent amongst
many of our theologians and many of the
leaders within this church
and unfortunately it is time
that the anti-typical elijahs
start speaking up
definitely because otherwise how can we
have that double portion we are supposed
to be doing our duty
so let's cut to the chase
say writes
and added to this
we have
the writings of ellen white for her time
which foretold
developments
of a worldwide
sunday law it's a stop thing
the worldwide sunday law according to
this was for her time
all that follows now was for her time
but that is making of non-effect the
testimony of the spirit of god 100
right and
and who is that who is the one
that makes of non-effect the testimony
it is the deceiver it's a deception
and according to the statement that we
read it is from satan yeah
i know this might seem very straight but
we need to show this
so let's see
what is
the problem with the writings of ellen
white so she seemed to have said
that there will be a worldwide sunday
law
that there will be persecution as you
had in the middle ages
that there will be a death sentence for
sabbath keepers
now he says that was for her time
the reality that we have today that we
actually see today
is
not in harmony with the situation that
we experience in the world today so none
of this is on the table according to
this writer
this is very interesting
and we cannot expect them to happen
in the near future
so martin
we cannot expect in the near future a
sunday law
we cannot expect
that there will be persecution as in the
middle ages or that there might even be
a death sentence the current reality
just doesn't show this picture
and we cannot expect it
so everything that we do where we show
the
developments in the world that's all a
conspiracy yeah so we definitely
the label sits well here all right so to
fill the gap
between what we believe the future will
bring
and the living reality of what we have
now to fill this gap
requires a
conspiracy theory
so martin everything
that we preach
everything
that we preach about
any of these issues
is a conspiracy theory
so in other words the second angel's
message
and the third angel's message is nothing
other than a conspiracy theory
according to this prominent theologian
at one of our universities
now he's not alone no
because we saw it at our prominent
universities in the united states of
america
and we've seen it in regards to the
pandemic that some people who do not
agree with the official line or even the
attitude that the church has taken
should be compared to jihadists yeah did
we have that definitely and to
witch doctors and all of these members
right so there's a very clear
line of distinction
and when it comes to asking for a
discussion on the issue even with
thousands of signatures
it is swept under the rug no discussion
is allowed so now we can see why because
everything that contradicts what these
people stand for
is apparently
a conspiracy theory
moreover
the prophet
is totally marginalized
nothing that she wrote is for our time
okay
so what does this conspiracy
theory
enable you to do it enables you to cling
to your traditional view
of biblical text and prophetic picture
even if the world events are totally
different
in other words he's denying absolutely
denying that there is even a vestige of
fulfillment of any of the prophecies
that we read in the testimonies
so all of this is and all of
the things we read in the spirit of
prophecy is also thrown into the history
books it's it's part of of history it's
got nothing to do with us
and any attempt
to align the prophecy with current
events is nothing other than conspiracy
theory
so this person obviously has no need
for the spirit of prophecy no none
whatsoever and even the
pillars
will have
will have to be seen in a new light we
don't need the second message and we
don't need the third message either
and then he has the goal to write
so the more you
wish for and the more you
want to expect these things to happen
the
more necessary it becomes in the light
of
the non-events in the world today
to have a conspiracy theory
so if you want to believe the bible if
you want to believe the spirit of
prophecy then you have no choice but to
become a conspiracy theorist
this is what he's saying
martin this is horrendous
so then he asks the question how can we
protect ourselves against these false
roads of conspiracy thinking
which can only flourish
in an environment of
distrust and fear
so martin conspiracy theories can only
thrive
in an environment
of fear and distrust
this is really very interesting
he says that the followers of jesus on
the contrary
are
confident
and have trust
not based on conspiracy theories
there's no sinners that plot
from an enemy
in other words if you're a follower of
jesus there's no sinister plot from an
enemy
excuse me has he missed the point from
genesis 1 onwards
and what about the statement that says
there will not be a moment
that the holy shadow of satan is that
spirit of prophecy
that you must throw away but
your adversary the devil walks around
like a roaring lion that comes from the
scripture it seems there is no there is
no problem
and there is no man of sin whom the lord
will destroy with the brightness of his
coming no because that was also in the
history so martin if you believe the
three angels messages if you believe in
the spirit spirit of prophecy you have
to be a conspiracy theorist and you are
an enemy
of the state and an enemy of the church
you are a straight list extremist full
of hate
this reminds me of that sermon that you
did about
heretics
book ends was the name yes
what the definition according to rome is
about a heretic and what the true
meaning is
this is the same
this is the difference between the real
meaning of a
conspiracy theorist
and their version so in other words
there is no sinister plot
from an enemy
there are no plans or
actions of other religious organizations
no global orientated
secret organizations
there's no trap that can take your trust
in god away
so in other words martin everything that
we believe according to the bible and
the spirit of prophecy according to this
theologian is a conspiracy theory so
there is no second angel's message there
is no third angel's message there is no
sunday law coming there is no
effort to get rid of those that are
inclined to keep the law of god
and the sad thing is he's not alone like
you've mentioned before no we've
mentioned theologians from our
universities from loma linda from
andrews university
from high up in the hierarchy
that all seem to have the same mindset
and martin
most of them become delegates and can
cast their vote yeah and there's another
state of affairs that said to me that
even this is the more liberal side but
you've even got the same thoughts in the
conservative side
yes
someone either we believe
the spirit of prophecy or we don't now
isn't that a fundamental belief it is
and you cannot say portions of it yes
and portions not that's the same as
saying there's portions in the bible
that i want to believe in portions that
i don't want to believe okay
why are they so obsessed
with conspiracy theories these people
why are they so
obsessed with it
because they are sitting in councils
where they have to
explain
some of the things that are coming out
of this church by some of the
evangelists and they have to marginalize
them
in order to be able to sit at the same
table and just
label them as straight-laced extremists
so here's an article in selected
messages and we've had this many times
but let's put it there again even in the
adventist church
we have far more to fear from within
than from without
the hindrances to strength and success
are far greater from the church itself
than from the world
unbelievers have a right to expect that
those who profess to be keeping the
commandments of god and the faith of
jesus will do more than any other class
to promote and honor by their consistent
lives by their godly example and their
active influence the cause which they
represent
but how often have the professed
advocates of the truth prove the
greatest obstacle to its advancement
the unbelief indulged the doubts
expressed the darkness cherish
encourage the presence of evil angels
and open the way for the accomplishment
of satan's devices so modern whenever
you want to cast doubt
on the spirit of prophecy as that
theologian did
and dump it in the trash heap of
conspiracy theorists
do you not qualify for this statement
yes you do
so what does the great controversy tell
us the sabbath will be the great test of
loyalty for it is the point of truth
especially controverty did he just dump
that in the waste paper basket yes
because he said that was only for her
time okay when the final test shall be
brought to bear upon men then the line
of distinction will be drawn between
those who serve god and those who serve
him not
while the observance of the false
sabbath in compliance with the law of
the state contrary to the fourth
commandment will be in a vowel of
allegiance to the power that is in
opposition to god the keeping of the
true sabbath in obedience to god's law
is an evidence of loyalty to the creator
did he dump that in the waste paper
basket yes
while one class by accepting the sign of
submission to earthly powers receive the
mark of the beast the other choosing the
token of allegiance to the divine
authority receive the seal of god that's
the third angel's message did he dump
that
and what did he call them conspiracy
theorists ah
heretofore those who presented the
truths of the third angel's message have
often been regarded as mere alarmists
straight-laced extremists
their predictions that religious
intolerance would gain control in the
united states the church and state would
unite to persecute those who keep the
commandments have been pronounced
groundless and absurd did we just read
that exactly the same words
we just read that yes
and these are the people that educate
our theologians and our youth i would
make an appeal to parents never send
your children to any of these institutes
where they teach this kind of infidelity
it has been confidently declared that
this land could never become other than
what it has been the defender of
religious freedom
didn't he say that the circumstances
today reflect ex none of what is being
predicted
but as the question of enforcing sunday
observance is widely agitated the events
so long doubted and disbelieved is seen
to be approaching
and the third message will produce an
effect which it could not have had
before
you either believe this or you believe
the theologian
you have a choice and then nothing
that's happening in the world today
makes any sense and has nothing to do
with prophecy so martin i'm afraid
we have the label
and we know that the label is an acronym
for heretic
god requires his servants to walk in the
light and not cover their eyes that they
may not discern the workings of satan
they should be prepared to warn and
reprove those who are in danger through
this through his subtlety satan is
working on the right hand and on the
left to obtain vantage ground he rests
not
he is persevering he's vigilant and
crafty to take advantage of every
circumstance
and turn it to his account in his
warfare against the truth
and the interests of the kingdom of god
do we have a duty to expose it and speak
about it and that's an important because
there's a lot of people that are going
to say
why what are you doing
you're turning your weapons against the
church no no i'm turning my weapons
against the false ideology in the church
and not against the church
this is the remnant
but unfortunately there are prophets of
baal within the remnant
it is a lamentable fact that god's
servants are not half as much awake to
the wilds of satan as they should be and
instead of resisting the devil that he
may flee from them many are inclined to
make a compromise with the powers of
darkness
he denied that anything that is even
remotely associated with what the spirit
of prophecy foretold in terms of the
papacy the
the law being made void etc
that that is all conspiracy theory so
let's just make sure again
god's word has given warning of the
impending danger let this be unheeded
and the protestant world will learn what
the purposes of rome really are only
when it is too late to escape the snare
she is silently growing in power her
doctrines are exerting their influence
in legislative halls
in the churches and in the hearts of men
so lada atuci has no influence on
humanity
but if we look at all the leaders that
we've shown in a previous episode
speaking the
exact
wording
of ladau that's a conspiracy martin
that's just conspiracy
she is piling up her lofty and massive
structures in the secret recesses of
which her former persecutions will be
repeated that's a conspiracy martin
stealthily and unsuspectedly
she is strengthening her forces to
further our own ends and when the time
comes for her she will strike
that's a conspiracy
all that she desires is vantage ground
and this is already being given her we
shall soon see and shall feel what the
purpose of the roman element is whoever
shall believe and obey the word of god
will thereby
incur reproach and persecution
potpourri is just what prophecy declared
that she should be
the apostasy of the latter times
you see
but if you
put this as conspiracy
the potpourri won't be against you no
he'll be a friend
you'll be the one who wants to help you
it is a part of a policy to assume the
character which will best accomplish her
purpose but beneath the variable
appearance of the chameleon she conceals
the invariable venom of the serpent
quote we are not bound to keep faith and
promises to heretics she declares shall
this power
whose record for a thousand years is
written in the blood of the saints be
now acknowledged as part of the church
of christ
it is not without reason that the claim
has been put forth in protestant
countries that catholicism differs less
widely from protestantism than in former
times
there has been a change
but the change is not in the papacy
catholicism indeed resembles much of the
protestantism that now exists because
protestantism has so greatly degenerated
since the day of the reformers
i believe that some of our theologians
have drunken of the wine of babylon
and sea matters in exactly the same
light as the protestant world has come
to see them and then unfortunately
presumptuously
say that the follower of jesus will not
do this no
here's a quote from the great
controversy as the protestant churches
have been seeking the favor of the world
false charity has blinded their eyes
they do not see but that it is right to
believe good of all evil and as the
inevitable result
they will finally believe evil of all
good
martin this is
so well put
instead of standing in defense of the
faith once delivered to the saints they
are now as it were apologizing to rome
for their uncharitable opinion of her
begging pardon for their bigotry
a large class
even of those who look upon romanism
with no favor
apprehend little danger from her power
and influence
martin can we say that the same then
applies also to
many of the leaders and theologians
within our own ranks it has to it is a
prophecy
many urge that the intellectual and
moral darkness prevailing during the
middle ages favored the spread of her
dogma superstitions and oppression
and that the greater intelligence of
modern times the general diffusion of
knowledge and the increasing liberality
in matters of religion
for better revival of intolerance and
tyranny didn't he just say that in his
article
anyone who predicts a revival of
intolerance and tyranny
is according to him
conspiracy theorist
and then according to the other article
which was lengthier
it seems to me that that is the thinking
right at the top
in many cases
the very thought that such a state of
things will exist in this enlightened
age is ridiculed
but now we're seeing a fulfillment of
prophecy you see that this is so
interesting so this article is actually
fulfilling this prophecy
this is the point
they are a fulfillment of prophecy and
they know it not now
need they not to be warned
it is true that great light intellectual
moral and religious is shining upon this
generation
in the open pages of god's holy word
light from heaven has been shed upon the
world
but it should be remembered that the
greater the light bestowed
the greater the darkness of those who
pervert or reject it
that is so sad because that is what if
you don't repent of what you say
like this article said
you will be
fulfilling that part of the prophecy as
well yes so rome is exactly what the
bible says it is
and what the spirit of prophecy says it
is and no theologian
and no leader
no matter how eloquent
can
negate it
a prayerful study of the bible should
show protestants the real character of
the papacy
and would cause them to abhor
and to shun it
now martin this does not mean that you
abhor and shun the people never does it
mean that
it means that you must expose the lie
and the false doctrines and the false
hope and the false salvation
and point them to jesus christ
as the only means of salvation
there's a great controversy between
christ and satan
and there is a great controversy between
the representatives of god
the remnant
and
the representatives of satan
and if you deny that great controversy
or if you dare to place it into the
realm of
conspiracies you are an agent of satan
but many are so wise in their own
conceit that they feel no need to humbly
seeking god that they may be led into
the truth
although priding themselves on their
enlightenment they are ignorant both of
the scripture and of the power of god
they must have some means of quieting
their consciences and they seek that
which is least spiritual and humiliating
what they desire
is a method of forgetting god which
shall pass as a method of remembering
him
that's brilliantly put right i think i
must read that again
what they desire is a method of
forgetting god
which shall pass as a method of
remembering him exactly the papacy is
well adapted to meet the wants of all of
these
it is prepared for two classes of
mankind
embracing nearly the whole world
those who would be saved by their merits
and those who would be saved in their
sins
here is the secret of its power
do you know martin we could have
a whole sermon
on that one statement
and i
i would request the people to drink it
in
doesn't the papacy stand for salvation
by works
aren't the sacraments
means to salvation
and yet
at the same time
it empowers the people like the mafia
and anybody who is associated with them
to carry on sinning
because they have this
treasury of merit which they can rely on
all the
other religions
even the heathen religions like the
amazon uh senate that they had so can we
call this a can we call this a christian
system you see but the problem is then
you go to the previous sentence that you
repeat it
they they are so presumptuous that they
think this is the will of god yes even
the these people that write these
articles correct
as the truth is brought into practical
life
the standard is to be elevated higher
and higher to meet the requirements of
the bible so martin is a contrast that
we have to accept this is not just a war
between two mindsets even within the
church
this has to do
with truth
and when you accept truth
truth has a sanctifying power
it's not just a question of going to war
it's a question of bearing the armor
and you can read the statements in the
bible as what what constitutes the armor
of god
and the belt of truth that's it if you
don't have it
then you haven't got your loins girded
so you have to have elevated standards
this will necessitate opposition to
fashion custom practices
and maxims of the world
so modern everything that the world
throws at you
and tells you is truth can you just
accept it no it has to be tested to the
law and the testimony you have to put it
into the prophetic picture okay worldly
influences like waves of the seas
beat against the followers of christ to
sweep them away from true principles of
the meekness and grace of christ
but they are to stand as firm as a rock
to principle it will require moral
courage to do this
so martin if you stand
with moral courage
for something
for example that your body is the temple
of the holy spirit and you will not
allow anyone to tamper with it
which is against your conscience
will it require
moral courage
definitely you cannot do it alone will
you have opposition oh yes
model independence will be holy in place
when opposing the world
moral independence
by conforming entirely to the will of
god we shall be placed upon vantage
ground so there are two vantage grounds
that's why i've highlighted this
there's the vantage ground that is given
the beast power
and she is utilizing it to spread her
abominations in that cup filled full of
abominations and the world is drinking
them but here's another vantage ground
based on scripture
and believing the prophets
and shall see the necessity of decided
separation from the customs and
practices of the world
martin so when we align ourselves with
the customs and practices
aren't we going contrary to god 100
be ye separate
we are not to elevate our standard just
a little above the world standard but we
are to make the line of demarcation
decidedly apparent yeah you have to
become well according to them a straight
straight-laced extremist
well let's see whether we get there
there are many in the church
who at heart belong to the world
but god calls upon those who claim to
believe the advanced truth to rise above
the present attitude of the popular
churches of today
where is the self-denial
where is the cross bearing that christ
has said should characterize his
followers
the reason we have so little influence
upon unbelieving relatives and
associates
is that we have manifested little
decided difference in our practices from
those of the world
one this is a very serious issue well if
we read this do we see in
our church
wrong application of music yes do we see
coercion
tactics yes so
again do we see exclusion tactics
definitely do we see marginalization
do we see name calling yes do we see
labeling
didn't we just read an article that
labeled people
okay
parents need to awake and purify their
souls by practicing the truth in their
home life
when we reach the standard that the lord
would have us reach
worldlings will regard seventh-day
adventists as odd
singular
straight-laced
extremists
i want to be
an odd
singular
straight-laced extremist
me too
even if it means the ire
of many of our leading individuals
we are made a spectacle unto the world
and to angels
and to men
as a statement from prophets and kings
in obedience to god's law there is great
gain
in conformity to the divine requirements
there is a transforming power that
brings peace and good will amongst men
if the teachings of god's word were made
the controlling influence and the life
of every man and woman
if mind and heart were brought under the
restraining power
the evils that now exist in national and
in social life
would find no place martin do we find
evils in national and social life the
world over the world over even in the
legislation that is being passed
from every home would go forth an
influence that would make men and women
strong
in spiritual insight and moral power
and thus nation and individuals would be
placed on
vantage ground
what kind of vantage ground do we want
this wantage grant the one with god
first peter chapter 5 be sober be
vigilant because your adversary the
devil as a roaring lion walketh about
seeking whom he may devour
didn't that article say there is no
enemy no
exactly he said 100 that's what he said
right
whom resists steadfast in the faith
knowing that the same afflictions are
accomplished in your brethren that are
in the world
but the god of all grace who has called
us unto his eternal glory by christ
jesus
after that ye have suffered a while make
you perfect establish strengthen you
settle you
to him be glory and dominion forever and
ever
martin if there ever was a time
when we need to have
the perfection of the righteousness of
christ
when there
ever was a time when we need to be
established in what we believe
so that we can be settled in the truth
so we cannot be moved
so that we can be
sealed and be ready yes and to be sealed
means to be settled in the truth that
you cannot be moved
then that time must be now
and then to him be the glory and the
dominion forever and ever who claims the
dominion now
satan satan claims it
and his agents are working hard on his
behalf yes shouldn't god's people be
even more zealous now is the time
now is the time let's pray
heavenly father sometimes things have to
be said
and there is a clear demarcation of
thought
we either walk in the one stream or we
walk in the other
and if the stream that we walk in is
labeled
then so be it if it is truth we want to
stand for it
and let us be odd singular
straight-laced
extremists in the eyes of the world
but let the god of heaven show the world
that we have believed the word of god
and trusted in his prophets
in jesus name i pray
amen amen
[Music]
you